so how many episodes is season two uh in
total
uh eight because i remember when we
spoke last time you were still figuring
out that number yes no it was figured
out i think uh 10 became eight uh
in some sort of you know streaming
uh i don't know but it somehow it became
eight episodes which was good i think
eight i quite like actually uh between
ten i've done six which is too few but
eight i think is is about right so uh
if you as long as you have zero filler
you can uh you can do eight
yeah i think that eight is uh um it's
interesting because eight is uh it
allows you to tell the story but there
generally is
no wasted scenes
yeah that's that that's the the the fun
of it you're really trying to you know
you got to make sure
every minute counts so you only have so
much time but i i i actually prefer it
that way
uh
then than having too much
and you gotta
i i totally get it and as an audience
member it's a pretty good number but um
which of your friends and family are the
biggest fans of the show and who asks
you for spoilers the most
uh it would probably be
my oldest son
who's 11 and uh who's seen some of the
show not all his show
um he actually knows
a lot of the underlying mythology kind
of where the show is going to go and he
is always clamoring for
when i'm going to reveal circles that we
have no plans to reveal anytime soon
he's getting away ahead of it uh he and
he's very monster centric as well he's
always trying to push me to put
more and more creatures into the show so
uh we have a lot of that going on as
well
that's funny i'm wondering how
influential uh his voice is in the
writers room
more and more so yeah absolutely
so uh the first season you made and i
could be remembering this wrong but it
was being made for tbs or tnt then it
switched to h to hbo max so when hbo max
decided to pick it up for season two um
did they give you additional funds like
how does that work yeah i know they uh
you know i for me it's just been a
continuous thing you know i i haven't
stopped working on the show since we
began season one
uh so yeah i know they've
they've kept us up and running and you
know whatever we need to do what we need
to do and they've been hugely supportive
uh
and then of course once we got into
actually you know making season two it
was in the middle of the pandemic which
we're still in the middle of uh so
obviously it was a very different
experience than than season one in terms
of the logistics of it all but um but we
got it done you know due to the you know
heroic efforts of uh our cast and crew
in south africa you know uh during
difficult conditions for
uh
sure i noticed that uh hbo max started
advertising season two when dune was on
the platform were you were you like oh
wow this is really cool i was super
psyched about yeah i um i i know denis
the director i made uh prisoners with
denis and i think he made an absolute
masterpiece with dune and i was so over
the moon that they uh they put our
trailer at the the front of it i was
like wow that's so great so great
does hbo actually tell you real numbers
or do they just say you're doing good
enough here's some money make another
one
that that's basically all i've heard
yeah i i don't get to i i i probably
wouldn't be fishing for specifics anyway
because i'm just you know i don't i
don't want to know i just want to know
that i can keep writing
but yeah yeah they keep it pretty close
to the best but they'll give you some
sense of how you're doing for sure
um in an ideal i think we talked about
this last time but i'm curious if it's
changed ideal world how many seasons
would you like this to go
i think five was my original uh
plan and that still stands i think you
could absolutely tell the story uh in
five seasons
it could go on beyond that but i think
you know in terms of what's in my head
today what i know now uh five seasons
feels and that was always kind of the
you know the original uh plan that it
was going to take about that long you
know to hit you know to get to where we
wanted to go and to tell the full story
so that it's still the case
uh i would imagine as you're writing or
continue writing things can get refined
you mentioned to me last time we spoke
that you had the very end figured out
have things like that like the big
things are they still sort of locked in
concrete or have they been tweaked as a
result of maybe where season two goes
you know it's kind of like i've used i
use this analogy it's kind of like this
house and you kind of have the the basic
architectural framework and that that
probably isn't going to change but as
you get into that house
and you start making those rooms and you
know and you start seeing it and you
live in it um it starts kind of talking
back to you and and you'd be a fool not
to listen to it so i think and that's
part of the great thing about writing tv
versus a movie
is your you know
when you're going beyond one season is
you're seeing it while you're writing it
and it just starts to inform the writing
you know as you're seeing these things
come to life
and the the context in which you're you
know changes
uh so
you you have to let that happen i think
you really to make the best show
possible
you have to keep aspects of it fairly
flexible or at least be willing to to
listen when it seems like it wants to do
something or a character wants to do
something or whatever the case might be
like i said i've seen the first three
episodes but i have no idea what you
want to tell people so a little generic
but what do you want to tease fans about
season two
uh well you know season two i think has
a lot to do with you know the season one
we saw the birth of mother's natural
child you know this this dark serpent
child and uh i don't think spoiling it
too much to say that that child does
survive uh into the second season and
your mother finds herself in an
interesting position where
she realizes that she actually feels
very connected to this monster uh that
you know no one else knows that uh where
this thing came from except for father
and uh it's endangering uh this colony
that she's joined it's endangering her
human children um and yet she starts
she's finding that she's
not really sure what she's going to be
able to do about it you know that she is
probably the only person who's really
positioned to uh to take this thing down
yet at the same time you know she's
feeling this this this connection to it
that it is her caregiving program is
basically assigned it uh
in her hierarchy of children you know a
a high degree of importance uh so she's
quite conflicted in that sense
um if you had
an unlimited budget
what would be the thing that you would
love to add to the show that perhaps the
parameters just can't do because
you know what i mean yes yes yes uh
it's really hard to say you know because
i think
so much of it and i've really kind of
trained myself this way is you know
what you can't do is kind of how you
build the story around you know the
whole idea that
as soon as you can do everything all of
your ideas kind of go down the drain
because it's just too much it's too much
choice too much i think when you're kind
of locked into a budget and you're like
well i can only build certain things i
can only show certain things
um it actually lends itself to ideas
more than
i can do anything you know what am i
going to do but to your question which i
totally avoided answering uh
[Laughter]
i probably would have
we probably would have done more
uh in terms of the war on earth and and
seeing more of that you know and and
which you know would have involved a
great deal of uh a budget uh you know
that we wanted to devote more to the the
new planet sure i mean
there are sequences that take place in
earth and i know those are not uh cheap
um you mentioned last time we spoke that
the plan was to do some more stuff on
earth in season two uh do we get any
more earth flashbacks or is that more
for season three
uh probably gonna be more of a season
three yeah i think we we will
we get more context and you know we're
definitely continuing on with that
mythology no doubt about it and but uh
it seems like we're not really going to
be flashing back to earth until season
three how does it work actually with hbo
max because obviously they took control
of the show when it comes to season two
how much is it you having to like pitch
the executives on your vision and what
you're thinking and like laying all that
out and how much you know what i mean
like how what's that dynamic like yeah i
think you know when
when it came time you know
when they told me that they wanted me to
start thinking about season two i kind
of went off and and came up with you
know i mean i had obviously a map for
the series but you know season by season
you really have to kind of
start building it out in the micro uh so
i had to kind of you know pitch them and
give them a some sense
of what to expect um but you know it's
not super detailed
it's kind of the broad strokes so they
have some idea like okay and you know
once after that then it's kind of you're
off to the races you're you're just kind
of in it and they kind of you know
they're very supportive and they do give
notes but for the most part they really
just kind of let the show
you know be what it wants to be you know
uh and i think you know because
sometimes you find yourself you're
writing a show and the network thinks
it's one thing and you think it's
another and you know that that never
ends well so i think
and i think with this show too i think
you know having ridley
as uh a defender of the show and you
know really helping to protect the
integrity of it that there you know
there hasn't been much in terms of you
know anyone trying to
take us out of our lane or you know turn
us into something we're not i
the network's been great uh how much is
in the first season you talk about the
radiation poisoning which it affected a
lot of people has that radiation
poisoning possibly affected marcus at
all or because there is a you know
market marcus is definitely an an
interesting person in season two yes yes
well it's interesting that that you say
that because there is something
uh
going on with marcus for sure and he
find when he's in the tropical zone he
does find that
the sun is having a strange sort of uh
you know he's reacting to it almost as
if his body is is like solar powered in
a strange way you know he's having these
weird sort of reactions to electricity
in the sun
so there is something going on there um
that may have to do with radioactivity i
you are onto something there i can't
give it away but i can say it is to do
with something that that happened in
season one it was that was kind of laid
out and uh in season two
uh
well i guess you'll see eventually it
does get revealed why it is that he is
uh that he has these powers
yeah i was going to say he seems a
little bit stronger a little bit
stronger yeah there's something going on
with him which of course marcus believes
has to do with the fact that he's the
prophet you know he thinks these powers
are coming from from seoul uh but uh but
we'll we'll find out if that's the case
uh as we get a little further into the
season
uh what are the who are the directors
for season two uh well you've got uh
ernest dickerson who did uh the first
and second episode uh you've got
sunuganera who did uh three and four
uh alex gabassi uh did five and six he
actually directed uh seven and eight
last year and we've got uh
lucas lucas atlan who's our producing
director direct uh directive seven and
eight
so uh
really really awesome directors and
again really trying to stick with
the template that ridley set up in terms
of you know the look and feel of this
world you know and trying to make sure
that it does just feel like
a long movie you know i think and not so
every episode isn't in some completely
stylistic universe
uh from the next
um have we seen the la i'm assuming we
haven't but have we seen the last of
mother's eyes
uh i i can't say for sure but i i i
would say uh
no we have not i'll go ahead and just
spoil that no the the eyes will
i was going to say it's way too good of
a
good right like
why he's something that we don't want to
happen right yeah i know it's too good
um so look obviously who the hell knows
um what's gonna happen in the future but
hypothetically would you be writing
anything on season three right now i am
i'm i'm working away on it um
you know who's to say whether or not
it'll get ordered to uh production if
we'll get to that point but uh i have to
keep working on it um because if it does
get ordered i just have to be because
we have no source material i have to
just keep writing it so as long as the
show goes on i imagine that that's my
entire universe you know i i'm like a
method actor i just except i'm a method
writer i just live in this this universe
this alien planet that's it uh
uh completely listen i already got to go
um uh they already you know they're
giving me the wrap-up signal but
obviously when the season is over uh if
it's possible to talk again uh about the
finale and stuff uh i would love to do
it that'd be great awesome hey listen
man uh nothing but the best thank you uh
thank you for your time and i really
can't wait to watch the rest thanks so
much